dark universe is going to be a modern
retelling of the classic Universal
Monsters films all the monsters the
people fell in love with the idea is to
honor what came before and to protect
the legacy of the monsters but to put
them in a new context and to add
elements to their stories welcome to a
new world of guns and monsters is that a
story that are passed down from
generation to generation and it was so
important for the studio if they were
going to honor them that they do them
you know steeped in integrity I love the
fact that they're the very first horror
movie they're the first monster movies
our ability to to fear the monster and
to sympathize with the monster I think
that's a big part of why they've endured
for so long they they reflect something
very human in all of us they want what
we want they want to connect they want
to be part of the world Society tends to
reject them which makes them monstrous
and I think we all feel a connection to
that idea and one way or another
[Music]
you